a diplomatic dispute in Central America
as Taiwan recalls its ambassador to
Honduras
this following an announcement on March
15 by Honduran president xiomara Castro
that Honduras would be re-establishing
diplomatic ties with China
sure we welcome the Honduran
government's positive statement to
develop relations with China we are
ready to establish and develop bilateral
relations on the basis of equality and
mutual respect
Honduras in Taiwan have had strong
diplomatic ties for decades by creating
a new diplomatic relationship with China
however those ties could now be broken
on Thursday Taiwanese foreign minister
Joseph Wu said Taiwan would continue to
try to preserve the Diplomatic
relationship with Honduras
but added that Taiwan would not compete
with China's spending in order to draw
in more support of its One China policy
the other side demanded a high price but
as we don't engage in Dollar Diplomacy
with China we've already entered a very
taxing phase but all our colleagues
posted in Honduras are still making
efforts we will try our best until the
very end
urian officials have denied allegations
that the country was seeking 2.5 billion
dollars in aid from Taiwan before
ultimately announcing the new diplomatic
partnership with China
during a recent bilateral meeting
between U.S and Honduran officials the
U.S expressed concern over Honduras
favoring China over Taiwan
honduras's foreign minister defended the
decision citing economic interests and a
desire for Honduras to attract more
foreign investment
the president made some general comments
on the decision made but obviously the
United States government commented this
is a sovereign decision from the
Honduras government and as such they
respect it
ongoing stat between nations is taking
place ahead of a visit by the Taiwanese
president to Guatemala and Belize next
week to of only 13 diplomatic allies
Taiwan has left
as China's influence continues to spread
and strengthen across Latin America
Al Jazeera